identify as jacked and some and
wonderful and successful those are my
preferred adjectives right you will hurt
my feelings if you don't refer to me as
jacked handsome intelligent charming and
so I don't have you have a right to
freedom of speech I don't have a right
to control your language that's not how
it works oh there's no right to not have
your feelings hurt there's no right to
control other people's language the
right is on the other side so yes people
should be polite and kind and civil
within reason but actually if you are
now trying to control someone else's
language and force them to call you
something especially something that you
are not you don't have a right to do
that at all at all that's not all right